few months ago I made this comment don't
play games with people but it's good to
test just to get to know them as best
you can people didn't like that very
much and that's totally fine my point
was ideally I would want for me and
whoever I'm dating to be in a situation
outside of both of our comfort zones to
see how we interact with each other call
it character research but I wanted to
hear more voices surrounding this topic
the Bible does say in a multitude of
counselors there is safety the
conversation you're about to hear is
with me and Dr Reginald Horton professor
of religion and psychology at Southern
Adventist University and his wife
LaShawn Horton a professor in the school
of nursing at Southern Adventist
University from arranged marriages to
testing your partner it's time to get to
the bottom of how to navigate Christian
dating
[Music]
how long have you been married oh we've
been married for 31 years
congratulations thank you so when you
were coming together you know maybe
dating or you were thinking about
proposing were both of your families on
board you think there was a push like
yeah sign off on this relationship well
I went to her dad and her her stepmom
I'm sorry her second mom second mom okay
and um
see um
I remember pops was cool
he had he was all right yeah I remember
was in the kitchen sitting at the table
and I told him I would ask him
I couldn't know her to marry me and like
I said he was entertained he was cool
but she drilled me away
uh okay yeah but I don't know if it was
just anxiety for her or what but anyway
her bio mom she um
I think she cried we saw all three of
them were at the table no well I left
there then my other mission was to go to
her mom or it was her mom it was really
one of those it's been 31 years so it
was a little it was in one of those
ordered in that order and so I went to
her mom I remember asking her
but she didn't give me any beat okay was
that the first time you were meeting
them oh no no no and that's good oh no
we date we add what two years of
involvement two years oh so you both we
dated about like two years before we got
married okay did you know each other
previously oh yeah oh yeah yeah we met
here at Southern wow yeah we met here at
Southern and and dated and
um dated for probably about a year and a
half before he proposed and my family
was on board his family was on board
well okay see she she has a different
relationship with her family than I did
yeah I'm sorry my family isn't Adventist
and so when I joined the Adventist faith
there seems to be this sort of divide
between me and my family but I still
love them and you know they you know I
still but their their level of
involvement in my life or me
uh involving them in my life was it
wasn't at the level that she was so I
I don't even remember telling my mom
I didn't work because we were at her
house yeah but I mean it wasn't like for
approval oh yeah yeah okay I was gonna
ask if there was any involvement between
your families or if there's any kind of
like Arrangement so to speak we had had
contact with his mom
um and I had gone to her house and so I
knew her she met me but it was nothing
in the way of having you know our
parents have a relationship prior to us
getting married and them you know
possibly arranging you know a connection
between us no it wasn't like that okay
okay so your relationship would be
called a self-selected marriage
it's interesting globally there are more
arranged marriages than self-selected
ones now looking at the United States
specifically you know there is both
there's arranged and self-selecting
which makes sense because there's such a
Melting Pot of a country to look at the
divorce rate between those two groups
the arranged marriage well their divorce
rate within that group is four percent
but with the self-selected marriages
it's 40 it's a big gap big yeah why do
you think that is
what is it about arranged versus
self-selected that seems better
well well
so his
because I did my dissertation uh my my
dissertation project was on
divorce okay and so
I I know a lot of the history behind
divorce in the U.S so and I'm not saying
your information is inaccurate
but I I wondered are we factoring in
this in part of our information for
example
um divorce started I think early 60s
with uh with Ronald Reagan when he was a
governor of California
and so that's why you come up with the
no-fault divorce now it's here and so
when you say started I mean
okay so okay the story is he wanted to
get out of relationship with his
previous wife in order to marry Massey
but he was governor okay so now that he
he wanted to get out of so back in the
day you couldn't do that you have to
have reasons to divorce your wife you
just couldn't just go to the courthouse
and say uh I want a divorce so I want to
divorce him no you have to have a
legitimate reason I don't know exactly
the reasons however he being the
governor of California changed that way
you can have a no-fault divorce you
don't have to have any fault with your
spouse so you can just do it and so that
started that now we all know uh
California and the influence that it
that it has on Western
Society so we do know that so when they
started other states fault so I'm
wondering based upon your stats
are we factoring that in that may have a
play as to why the increase is different
than the U.S and other countries I want
is there a link to that that's what I'm
trying to say okay okay so but it
doesn't deny the fact that divorce is
High here than in other countries uh so
yeah so when you said that you sent me
there okay oh that's good yeah but but
that is not to discredit what you just
said or anything like that it's just you
made me think about that now people may
divorce more frequently because of the
laws changing in the way that they
divorced right right so there may not be
a happiness correlation or anything
right that is just right I'm tired of
her I'm tired of him right
whereas in other coaches you could be
tired but you can't get out and you
can't get out yeah so yeah now I would
love to see the level of Affairs in
other countries versus here that's good
you have to stay in the marriage and you
want out you're not happy typically
um Affairs and I'm trying to say it's
it's
but anyway I think there's a link oh
yeah I see your point for sure but
that's why I guess it's important that I
um I looked up the stat for the United
States specifically
um but
another consideration is although
something might be legal it may not be
culturally okay so in this family you
don't diverse I don't care about what's
going on like in the court so that's
also something to consider
um because there are certain cultures
within this General culture
um are more into arranged marriages and
self-selected ones so that is something
to to factor in but so let me ask you
this okay so is there a late two
arranged marriages and why they've
stayed together can get a four percent
versus the U.S so so what is the leak
there what what's causing them to stay
together is it because they were
arranged or what so yeah in my study
there was so many different answers and
not one was locked in and of course it
depends on the culture but yeah it was a
lot of
um you know it was positive and negative
the negative was shame there's a lot of
Shame surrounding and pressure
surrounding that if you were to divorce
so there's more of an instance of okay
let's make this work it's for the
benefit of both of us just make it work
um but the other side is that um when it
comes to arranged marriage of course
there is this a connection between
parent of child and child they want
what's best for the child
um most of the time it's a loving thing
but it's also like a transactional thing
in terms of um I want what's best for my
child can this person provide for my
child if they're the right fit for my
child so there's a lot more research so
to speak that goes into it so that the
likelihood of them lasting is a lot
better because there are all these
opinions involved there's a lot more
research involved counsel yes exactly
support community so it's just better
from that perspective but don't we do
that unconsciously I mean yeah in our
society you know we have
part of me friends that have children
are children's age and if they're both
single and we feel that they're a good
match we'll say well what is your son
doing what is your daughter doing do you
think they would be interested in my son
so we do that unconsciously it's not
done in a in a formal way as some
cultures may do but I think you know
subconsciously we do that well but that
leads me to my next question because
there's been an attack on the family in
that the kind of relationship between
parent and child is different to the
point where a lot of times parents don't
know their the real Spirit the real
character of their child so do you think
that arranged marriages would actually
even work even if the parents are
genuine in trying to find a spouse for
their child knowing that there's a lack
of relationship there would it work in
today's society I see what you're saying
I think that for our family my husband
has made a very conscientious
um
he's created a very conscious interest
framework for our family and that
framework is one that includes open
dialogue with our children
our children are now 21 and 23 and we
still have them come to us for counsel
and wisdom as it pertains to
relationships now with that being said
of course we don't know everything in
their lives as adults that they do
outside of our watchful eye but we do
know that we've built a foundation of
communication that bonds us in a way
that may not be traditional according to
what you're saying but because we have
that Foundation we still are able to
communicate with our children and they
will tell you that we would not choose a
partner that you and Daddy are not
comfortable with
but I think to your point what you're
saying is that many children don't have
that type of relationship with their
parents that trust that Bond and so they
could care less what their parents think
about their significant other to their
detriment I think it's dangerous because
I believe that
as a married couple for over 30 years of
experience knowledge and Walking with
God that it would be detrimental to them
not to listen to our wisdom and our
counsel so I think children can do
themselves a disservice when they're not
willing to take heed from parents who
have traveled
years before they've traveled
that'd be my thought that's good well
how do we fit Independence in there or
should it be fit in at all on the part
of the child
well
and for us as the parents
I think the independency comes for them
when there is this methodology or this
approach to how we convey information
is this
authoritarian type information that
we're giving out
or are we just sharing information with
them hey
if if I were
I probably or hey I would if I were you
versus oh no she can't come to this
house or he can't and so they know that
at the end of the conversation the
decision lies with them
either way go
because because we feel
we tried to help you and yet you still
with that role but it's not gonna
distance us at all but anyway but yeah
they understand that when they do come
hey Mom Dad here it is
what do you think and then they go away
actually make decisions it's not us
making it for them and I think they they
enjoy that uh I don't want to give any
particulars but there was a certain
um place that they would wanted to go in
and seeing things that nature and I said
I I wouldn't go to watch that if I was
with you guys in the Lord blessed they
were Midway through it and they got up
and now
but we until now we're going to run back
in this house if you go to that you know
take your clothes and get out yeah we go
to that extreme lose it out I wouldn't
and then the Holy Spirit convicted them
yeah and they got us enough right and so
they know that when they do come that
that that is their option we're not
pigeon holding them too you gotta do
this if you don't do it these are the
Alternatives I got a strong supportive
role oh there's the information you make
the choice you also do the consequences
we're here to support you through them
but I have to deal with the consequences
right decision right I love that right
okay so let's change Garrett's hair
um because it sounds like you are more
for self-selected with a lot of support
there
um why I'm okay with Arrangements I am
too yeah I would say too but I think
it's a it's a more modernized yes okay
your tradition traditional yes I think
arrangements are are good when the
parents
are being led by God yeah absolutely
yeah
um that's foremost yeah okay and so
not by any other motive or whatever have
you typically when you talk about a
raised marriage especially in different
countries there's a benefit for the
family right and so that's where you get
that line so that's why sometimes it
works and sometimes it does for me
that's my interpreter and so a more
modernized is what you kind of describe
right right and and I guess my thoughts
as it relates to Eastern tradition of
arranging marriages would be that the
kids had no say so so a modern version
for me and my husband I think would be
we present someone to you that we think
you know we've seen we've engaged with
they seem to have the qualities that fit
qualities you're looking for here this
person is now you can decide if you want
to you know choose to be with that
person or not it is your choice and I
think that that's how God does us he
gives us the choice he lays things out
for us the way we should go and then he
says now you choose you choose so that's
how I think we would align with that
because I think there's value in seeing
good qualities in someone and saying oh
this is a good person you should
consider getting to know them yeah
that's good yeah I I appreciate the
Bible and its presentation of arranged
marriages it's actually pretty specific
about the involvement of the children
um just an example
um with uh when Abraham sends his
servant right and then they found Rachel
uh-huh the Rachel's family asked her
specifically you know are you okay with
marrying this man you want to wait a
couple weeks I just loved that and yeah
and that made sure she was everyone was
on the same page that's good but when it
comes to people who decide to go to the
self-selected route what do you think
the purpose of dating is as they're
trying to approach marriage and maybe
they're not trying to approach marriage
but what is the purpose it's true
biblical purpose or is there a Biblical
purpose of dating I wonder that by me a
whole nother thing but
uh I'm trying to think I'm not sure well
while you're thinking let me say let me
add this while he's thinking I think
that the Bible admonishes us when he
says that
um you know it was not good for man to
be alone
uh in the garden when he created Adam
and he created the species and he gave
everyone like him his own
and then when he saw Adam and said you
know what this isn't right you're alone
uh let me give you a help me let me
create something from you that would be
your equal companion and so I think that
the purpose of dating is for marriage I
think that that was God's design that
was something he created in the garden
and if I was to say a Biblical purpose
of dating would be to marry it's not
just to hang out and you know chill and
whatever they do now but it was to
establish a covenant relationship and
grow a family I believe yes heavy words
Covenant relief Covenant Covenant under
God yeah I I thinking we I think
it'll be hard to find an actual
mimic
dating situation
in the Bible like it is today because
when you think about it it was to go
back to uh Abraham's servant finding
Isaac's wife right
there was no time that we know of yeah I
remember calling that well the time
frame may have been was the Trap exactly
that's about it but he never seen her up
until she arrived and so
um
so yeah so I don't know if we're finding
that uh but doesn't mean we can't date
should we always uh just go straight
into marriage no I don't think so I
don't think that's uh I don't know I
wouldn't want to say that but I will
stick with the purpose uh I think what
we find today is dating has become
uh it's experiment I just want to
experiment uh with the person and when
you start experimenting with people
oh man it's it's rough it can create a
lot of issues
uh unwarranted issues that can really be
detrimental to a person in their
character their person so to speak when
you compare would you compare
experimenting with exposure what if
someone's just looking for exposure so
they know what is good what is not good
well maybe how many yeah once again
you know it's your choice you can do
that
but understand I've you know dealing
with couples
dealing with
um young adults and dating
that's kind of sticky and
um
I wonder are we equipped well enough
to do that in a healthy way that's my
concern oh well that well that's good so
we we nailed that the purpose of dating
is supposed to lead to marriage the
Covenant relationship what does that
process look like then because this is
this is a big deal this is a big
decision and so someone who may be in
that phase dating what should they do to
let themselves know that hey this is
someone that I can actually marry
because that's the point isn't it and so
if I'm not willing to marry this person
I should probably break it off but but
how do I how do I get to that to that
phase that's
best the best way
see me excuse me I gotta step up on this
let's see what we're doing is
we're taking an element out of date
which is the Holy Spirit
competently
mentally
I just can't select this person right
because there are a lot of things that I
want but they just may not be good for
me uh in a person oh there may be some
things that I want that the person may
display
um or or or or they're making something
they display that made I'm not looking
for but that may be the very thing that
God's trying to get you to to correct
you so so we we take that element out so
to me if I'm dating today one of the one
of the
um approaches that I would take is to
make sure it's me and the spirit going
through this thing and I'm like hey what
do you think what do you think show me
some things reveal some things to me
yeah uh not only about this person but
about myself that's good and so um I
think we take that element out
especially I don't know
I'm assuming that this was be talking to
a Christian audience and so and that's
who I'm speaking to and so but we even
in our Christian Journey we know we
don't factor that in we don't we'll
everybody tell spirit and say Hey you
know we don't and it's more so just
Consulting you know sitting there
meditating and a lot of times we don't
do that and so I remember
knowing
just our journey was we were like best
prayers on campus
we had we had a we had a date every day
Sunday well Monday through Thursday it
was right in the cafeteria and then we
would eat for dinner every day we heard
another uh afraid of my house
and so
um
I almost missed that missed her because
I was in this well we just greed you
know and so
um but it's when I began to pray and God
said well you know so you know you may
want to consider okay so and then
started everything so yeah so so when
you ask sorry I sit back
that's excellent that that was really
good I think um
in relationship to the question you
asked the process of dating
um I think along with
the Holy Spirit guiding your steps
through the process and that's so
important because we can get so caught
up in the things that we see
but God looks at the heart we see the
outside and the outside might be
glittery and glamorous and all shiny
but if you haven't gotten to some of
those heart things then you may yeah
yeah so I would say part of that process
is
getting to know each other and that
comes through conversation yeah really
being able to talk openly about some
things and and of course that can kind
of take time this is why what my husband
said is so key about us and that was
that we had a friendship so at the very
base of our relationship was a
friendship where we could talk and so we
had already started to build a trust in
one another that helped with the
communication process communicating is
challenging and there's difficulty there
especially when you're trying to
communicate difficult things or have
things that you've dealt with in your
past that you're trying to convey
and so part of that is having a
foundation that is at the very base
level of friendship because that begins
the process of building a trust that
allows you to communicate one with
another and and communication opens up a
lot of things that you're not just gonna
see just right looking at the person and
saying oh they look so good or she's so
hot or this that you're not going to see
all of that and so communication is key
okay that's good once again we always
tell young adults yeah
he looked
he looks fine yeah yeah that's what it
was
hot back good absolutely but but see
once again that's our
idea what a we want
and sometimes it doesn't even take time
like right how committed are you to that
person if there's an accident or
something
that's correct what you do but you
brought up communication it was very
interesting some would say that actions
speak louder than words so what do you
think about curated scenarios within a
relationship where you are trying to
take the person out of their comfort
zone just to see how they would respond
just to get to know their character that
much better they can't put they can't
save face they can't do anything like
that you just want to see their their
response or reaction what do you think
curated curated created like created
scenarios that and I think you did that
very well with other couples yeah you
you must you may not even remember but
he had he had a group no not a he had a
group of couples that it was about three
couples that he would have them cooked
together he would have what you you tell
what you had them doing and this ended
up breaking up two of the couples right
yeah yes couples that were thinking
about getting married he took them
through different scenarios that they
had to work together in that's good yeah
they were two of the three decided that
marriage was not for them we would try
to assimilate marriage and so that was
that was part of my dissertation project
now the actual yeah and so what we did
was I just created scenarios
as if they were mad and so there were
some things they had okay so you you
were on the outside putting them in
these different like let's just say from
the position of a counselor maybe um
these dating people go to seek help from
a counselor and then you put them in
these different scenarios but what if
one party
had that idea to do it and they did it
or created it for them to experience
together or for the other party would
you say that that's a necessity or would
you actually say that that's
manipulative on that person's part
if they were to create a scenario and
not and keep the other person in the
dark and see what comes up comes out
well but and I love how you finalize
about saying in the dark manipulative
with me would be they're not aware of
what's going on
how that was the point if you give it
and tell them you're doing it all right
you know with support they they may not
be real you know going through the
process it's a good question I
personally think it's a good idea to be
honest I think that
um you you know there's there's nothing
wrong with evaluating someone's
character like we're out to eat and
let's say you know you open the door or
he didn't open the door or I don't have
any money and you know I was supposed to
be paying well how is he going to
respond in this situation
um or
um I he I'm rude to the to the waitress
yeah uh you know what is he going to say
how does he respond to me how does he
relate to the way those kind I don't see
anything wrong with seeing how a
person's character
will will come out in the I will if it's
on a continual
okay
it was like taking sat forever so what's
the balance so that boundary will be you
know
um every three scenario you really you
really
the best evaluated to me is and what you
use is character
why we have to generate a scenario to
figure that out
just being a Wilder person
go home see how he talks to his mother
yeah that's the scenario oh that's good
uh look at how he treats his sisters or
if you have any you know so those sort
of things kind of
would manifest itself as a person's
character so I don't know for me I I
wouldn't want nobody to cook meal enough
testing plan and not let me know but
then again yeah I could fade it you know
and just be good for now so but I would
rather for you to do it in at a more
authentic way and the best way to do it
and you said it earlier is being around
the person spend time look at how they
interact with other people
and then you begin to develop your sort
of testing scores so I think there's a
middle ground here where both of you can
be right because
um there's one thing to to be on the
side of you have all the control and
sense of you know what's going on and
the other person's left in the dark
versus you both are out of your element
let's say going camping or like cooking
together and so things might arise
naturally where now you can both observe
each other how are we getting through
this so it is a test in such a way but I
don't think there's any manipulation
manipulation involved because both of
you are just trying to get through it
yeah yeah okay that's good that's good
that's a good good medium I just know
for me
I mean just imagine going into your
classroom teaching oh we're having a
test today yeah you didn't tell me every
every day
it's about you mean your syllabus so
just imagine how comfortable you would
feel with that but what if you say to to
the person you're dating
um I'd like for us to do some just
pop-up scenarios you come up with
something and I know yeah we're talking
about and see how we respond in the
situation and you don't tell me when you
do them and I won't tell you when I do
mine I'll lay out the ground rules
and be how it fares I mean but I like
the idea I mean we didn't do that that
was never a part of an equation where
you have to go in kind of thinking do I
accept it was different 30 years ago you
both came together and what I view is
like the perfect scenario because you're
just friends there was no like oh let me
make sure I sit like this because I I
would like him or I know he likes me and
trying to get his attention right you
were just relaxed you set your mind you
got to know each other's character for
what it is and then a relationship
around but for someone who doesn't have
that right now he brought up time I
think time tells all that's fantastic
some people date for two years you're
like okay I know this person for sure
let's get married yeah but what if
someone only has for whatever reason six
months then please don't forget my
posture but I'm comfortable
[Laughter]
for 30 years 31 years I've been on this
testing
so the thing that testing is something
that I could I need to do with within
six months
it's a good thing to think that way
but make sure you think alongside with
that that this element or this piece
needs to be in that testing too which
means you're going to be on it in a
relationship because people keep
evolving exactly so it's not just for
dating
uh you know uh it's it's it's it's
unknowing that's what I'm trying to say
and so oftentimes these terms which we
use are are I will say subtle terms but
these terms by which we use are are
terms that are we're just being
Innovative with language but at the end
of the day it's still what this is so
the journey right so so the thing that I
and then I don't know how you said
earlier you know six months I can date
for six months or six years
trust me we dealing with the issue trust
me uh I had a couple two different
couples a little older than the other
and women
so there go guarantees yeah and date so
uh the difference with testing in dating
and testing in marriage is that
we hope that you won't get out of your
marriage if someone fails the test
uh we hope that you will have gained
some
formative assessments throughout the
dating process to bring you to a
summative
evaluation of a person okay formative
meanings meaning little things that
you've seen throughout the relationship
that have created
a formation of an evaluation of a person
for you to make a sound decision
for marriage okay and you can call them
tests you can you know whatever
but hopefully you've made some general
summations of that person that have said
to you I can marry this person
under god with God leading and guiding
everything is not going to be worked out
at that summation right but you know
that God has led you to make this
definitive Choice there may be some
other formative tests that come in
marriage
and then the information you get your
data yeah
it's it may be scary
and it may scare you from where God is
trying to get you to yeah he made me try
to lead you to that person yeah who
probably felt every one of those tests
put out there
just because the end of the day I always
tell people that the other day marriage
is about stopping well I mean
he uses her to perfect my character work
things out sorry work things out with me
so that I can be saved it is vice versa
but all these testing that we may give
to a person there you go
right right well he wasn't receiving the
cheating past the test and he didn't
pass then yeah at the end of the day
yeah but God may have that person for
you because he's trying to say and often
we don't look at relationships like that
that's good you know I could I could
easily be good about myself
I could be the best
Christian person Godly person
um
but when you put in when you're a
community oh my goodness carrot carrot
that's right find things about yourself
you didn't even know yeah where did that
come from absolutely especially in a
marital relationship starting with you
could give me a general dating or
relationship advice for those preparing
for marriage who may be quite nervous
about this task of finding a partner
from the man's perspective from the
woman's perspective what piece of advice
would you give
I think my advice would be
um
for the women
would be to hold on
we live in a society
where
we have many variables
one we know of is that there are more
women in this world than there are men
um
two particularly if you're in the
Christian realm there are more women in
the church than there are men
um
and so
and then three we are up against so much
of
um the evils of this world if you will
um you know with not even having to go
deep into it but dealing with you know
sexual addictions and and pornography
and and so much of those kinds of evils
that cloud
the judgment and Cloud the
ideology around what it means to be in
relationship
and so I would um say to the women hold
on
that God hears
and God sees
and he knows what is best for each of
you
and that he has the plan already laid
out for you as it relates to
relationship
um with someone of the opposite sex so
hold on
do not be weary and doing well
but to hold fast and persevere in
whatever God is telling you to do
and walk with the Holy Spirit through
this
season if you are dating
and if you haven't started dating you
know continue to just hold fast and
continue to trust the Lord that would be
my uh piece of advice related to that
because Menace
so visual when it comes to selecting
women
my caution would be to them
because it is a caution you know we have
to be careful
um
do you know
try to get at the woman's Beauty
than just her out appearance wow
because that keeps you in this thing
called dating in relationship
there is no perfect woman
it's good um John ortberg in his book
everybody's dull till you get to know
them until you get to know them
says that we're all Irregulars
so if you're waiting for her to be the
perfect woman
yeah I'm sorry
uh not so angle that so
in a beauty
that's good credible
yeah I understand she you know she's not
gonna be and even if she was who says
you're able to match that all right now
say that so say that it's both in trying
to find that perfect person but also
building yourself up to be a perfect
person for someone else
thank you so much more than welcome this
was really fun I enjoyed it so much
thank you for having us
I hope you enjoyed this conversation
between me and the Hortons did you learn
something new or do you have a piece of
advice to add write it in the comment
section below we're able to broadcast
these conversations and create all sorts
of content because the supporters who
donate monthly to Little Light Studios
please consider our monetary
contribution today you can find more
information by going to our website
littlelifestudios.tv slash donate see
you next time on LED live
[Music]
welcome to the video Bible study Series
where we will explore a variety of Bible
topics using video and print what is
humility do we need God's law can I
understand the Holy Spirit yes you can
and we're going to solve that today in
five minutes or less they're designed to
engage You by watching a five minute
video having a discussion on the topic
and Diving deeper into it with a lesson
study
each study asks questions has discussion
points and or has activities
overall we developed this project for
you to have a closer walk with Jesus as
you explore relevant topics either in a
group setting or on your own we hope you
find these a blessing if you want more
information go to
www.littlelightstudios.tv or find us on
your favorite social media platform
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
thank you
every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know you're
thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
[Music]